[Musique]
c'est une route à la pointe sud du
continent
et une nouvelle aventure pour deux
copains noël le français et crise le sud
africaine
[Musique]
ce sont des prisonniers qui ont
construit cette route
tu imagines ils ont tout fait à la main
tout à la main les ont dû mettre un
temps fou
et combien sont morts ici
aucun point d'eau des nuits glaciales
bienvenue dans le sport berg la montagne
noire
c'est un sacré périple avec sa dose
d'adrénaline
à gauche si on sort de la piste il ya au
moins 200 mètres de vide
c'est très long joie ici
[Musique]
dans des endroits comme ça t'as pas
droit à l'erreur tu vas rester vigilant
chaque seconde ces quelques derniers
kilomètres sont
particulièrement difficiles
[Rires]
c'est un scoop
ça fait partie du jeu plus besoin
d'aller à la gym
tout a commencé par de simples vacances
à la fin du siècle dernier noël tombe
amoureux de l'afrique du sud puisse y
installe pour faire partager sa passion
du pays à des visiteurs privilégiés
vingt ans plus tard il est toujours en
quête de territoire secret dans lesquels
tracer de nouveaux circulent je lis à
l'expression des fléchir de paysages
parce que avec
mon ami christopher depuis cinq ans on
fait les voyages en organise des voyages
on essaie de trouver d'autres
destinations des endroits qui n'ont pas
été encore je veux pas dire piétiner
mais qui n'ont pas été visités déjà
visité par d'autres bien ça ça me fait
vibrer beaucoup
quatre heures de vertige au volant
puis les deux ouvreurs de route as le
col
quel magnifique journée
on a vraiment de la chance
pour eux et pour les futurs visiteurs
qu'ils amèneront jusqu'ici le voyage ne
fait que commencer le meilleur est
devant eux ou plus exactement au dessus
d'eux premier décollage sur cette piste
improvisée
c'est parti
avec leur petit ulm noël et chris vont
s'attaquer à une barrière naturelle
[Musique]
le massif qu'on voit devant nous ce sont
les montagnes ou territoires
c'est la frontière entre le désert du
karoo et l'océan
[Musique]
du minéral au végétal
comme par magie l'afrique vient fleurir
en plongeant dans l'océan
[Musique]
un jardin d'éden qui s'étire sur 400 km
un ruban vert et une route côtière
[Musique]
la garden route
la route des jardins
[Musique]
et
la garden route c'est un monde vert riz
et luxuriant
cette texture ses couleurs en trouve ici
toutes les nuances de vert
c'est magnifique
partout l'océan indien à découper la
côte
ils entrent parfois dans les terres pour
dessiner des lagunes comme ici à nice
n'a une curiosité qui mériterait sans
doute une halte dans le circuit qu'ils
ébauche
accompagner nos visiteurs et les faire
survoler cet endroit ce serait
merveilleux d'ailleurs je n'ai jamais
rencontré de gens qui n'aiment pas volé
voici la péninsule d'euros berg
une réserve naturelle qui intéresse
beaucoup les deux explorateurs ici leurs
voyageurs pourront jouer les robinson
vous voyez cette forêt sur la gauche ce
sont des arbres qui ne pousse qui si ils
ont des centaines d'années
quand je vole j'éprouve un sentiment de
liberté absolue
c'est un honneur pour moi je sais que
peu de gens ont cette chance
et puis volé avec mon meilleur ami que
demander de plus
liberté en vol
liberté au sol en ulm n'atterrit partout
on
va finir la journée pour la nature au
milieu de nulle part sans gaz sans eau
sans électricité
juste une boîte d'allumettes
quelques branches
on va faire griller une petit morceau de
viande
on n'est pas bien au menu les saucisses
traditionnelle du pays mais birders que
les colons néerlandais ont apporté avec
eux au xviie siècle on va se régaler
quel plaisir tu vois les journées comme
celle-ci
on a l'impression qu'elles durent des
semaines poésie on a fait tellement de
choses aujourd'hui
vu du ciel on passe à côté des détails
noël et chris ont laissé leur ulm
avec un side car ils vont passer la
région au peigne fin
[Musique]
il y à la route nationale mais quand on
connaît bien la garden route
c'est aussi qu'il y a plein de chemins
de traverse
alors on enfourche sa moto et on part à
la recherche d'endroits extraits en
vidéo
ouais vraiment si on aime laventure la
garden route c'est l'endroit où il faut
venir
on se croirait très loin de l'océan et
pourtant la côte à quatre hommes km à
vol d'oiseau
vol ahvaz
quel endroit fantastique pour amener des
visiteurs ici ce serait vraiment pour
des gens qui préfèrent camper plutôt que
d'aller à l'hôtel
c'est tout ce qu'on voit autour de nous
regarde toute cette variété d'arbres
c'est merveilleux le regard de sa
crise et noël feront venir leurs
visiteurs au compte gouttes
pour l'instant rares sont les
privilégiés a profité de ce tapis vert
un maquis unique au monde
appelait le film hausse
un kaléidoscope d'espèces 20 % des
plantes de toute l'afrique sur
0,002 % de sa surface
[Musique]
ce paradis vert à ses gardiens les
bénévoles passionnés par la flore locale
attention il ya un petit ruisseau
à leur tête diane 73 ans
qu'un nul vous pouvez sortir le gps s'il
vous plaît
le dernier arrivé dans la bande c samedi
les 25 ans il est étudiant en botanique
m'ont dit cette planquer les barbus en
équipe chose de ces petits poils au bout
de ces fleurs
sont en commun ses protège barbu est pas
qu une touche son nom scientifique est
un peu plus compliquée protean mairie
folie à
110 les est ce que cette plante te
paraît menacé sur une échelle de 1 à 5
tu mettrais combien je dirais sac moi
j'aimais trine 2 à 2 ah oui oui deux pas
plus 5 c'est trop c'est vrai que 5 c'est
un peu exagéré
on en a vu beaucoup par ici
apprennent beaucoup vous avez vu je fais
encore pas mal d'erreurs et ils sont
toujours là pour corriger c'est ce que
j'aime il me transmettent énormément
ce savoir 110 les veut en faire quelque
chose
semer des graines à son tour
il a pensé aux enfants de son quartier
du township au paradis il n'y a que 20
minutes de bus
sandy les ce grand frère va leur faire
découvrir leur propre pays
[Musique]
tiens un crabe il a combien de pâtes il
en a huit
attention il va te penser
venez je vais vous dire ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui approchez vous
vous voyez cette plante est bien elle
pose un problème aucun animal ne la
mange alors elle pousse partout elle
tombe toute l'eau du sous-sol et ça
c'est une vraie menace pour nos réserves
d'eau
vous buvez tous de l'eau du robinet
eh bien elle vient delà de cette rivière
c'est pour ça que c'est très important
de protéger notre écosystème
même les amoureux des plantes savent
qu'il faut parfois les arracher
suivez moi on va essayer d'en arracher
le plus possible
allez on y va on tire dessus
à 2,3 on a eu
un débarras
tiens pour cette plante regarde la page
c'est une plante par plastic de la
famille des acacias
voir
sentir
touchés
dans cette classe verte tous les sens
sont en éveil
à temps
prend là dans ce sens là
oui tu as raison c'est mieux comme ça
l'ex j'ai mon petit plan nature et avec
cette vue basse et suis tranquille
leicester est je viendrai me reposer
ainsi quand je serai stressé que
j'aurais trop de choses dans la tête
c'est l'autre trésors de ce ruban vert
et on ne peut l'admirer que du ciel
depuis près d'un siècle des maisons
d'architectes exceptionnel fleurissent
sur la garden route
retour dans les airs avec nos deux
aventuriers on commence à voir des
maisons sympa pour l'instant il ya
surtout des villas de luxe pour
sud-africain fortunés mais les stars
internationales rodger federer par
exemple sont de plus en plus sensibles à
cette riviera du bout du monde
on a vraiment de la chance de voir tout
ça d'en haut ces propriétés privées ne
sont pas accessibles depuis la route
nous nous sommes des privilégiés on peut
les survoler vue du ciel c'est
incomparable
il y a le style classique et aussi des
folies de millionnaire
là tout au bout près du sable c'est le
château fort de deuil dit c'est un
endroit très spécial
regardez cette plage privée
[Musique]
posé sur la dune une soucoupe volante
c'est la villa d'un banquier d'affaires
une petite pépite construite par l'un
des grands noms de l'architecturé sud
africaine il s'est fait connaître en
dessinant les plus beaux lodge du pays
chris et noël sont tombés dessus par
hasard il tente une visite improvisée
bonjour mes revenus
le propriétaire est à londres le gardien
est fier de faire visiter le domaine
elle a été fini en 2013
la construction a duré deux ans
le terrain fait un peu plus de 24
hectares et la maison elle fait combien
de mètres carrés à peu près 10 800 m
c'est juste un peu plus grand que chez
moi
oui un petit peu
un
vrai palais à la fois design et écolo
venez on va monter par là vous allez
voir la maison en entier
intention c'était d'être écologique dès
le départ de minimiser notre impact sur
la nature
indigènes on l'a déterré pour les
travaux on les a replanté sur le terrain
d'agen
lagarde anne roth c'est encore un
endroit méconnu et peu de gens en
profitent
faire découvrir ce petit paradis que les
gens qu'on emmène avec nous il en tombe
amoureux et qu'il revienne c'est une si
belle région nous sommes vraiment bénie
le vivre ici
fertile et fragile la route des jardins
a besoin de ses gardiens
pour qu'ils restent demain un paradis
sur terre à la pointe
tout à la pointe de l'afrique